he used his Mac to search for widows and
crack
yes Hunter search history no surprise
but it still will make you want to
bleach your eyes according to the Daily
Mail I wonder if they deliver
Biden search history on his Infamous
laptop reveals an obsession with
homemade crack cocaine and MILF porn for
a second I thought I was reading to
Rose's personal ad
but credit to Hunter he knows what he
likes did he also type in hot Ukrainian
gas companies and Chinese government
officials seeking romance uh some
political commentary there enjoy it this
week the mail published his browser
history over a six day period in March
2019 which is the peak of the Biden
mating season
during that time he reportedly visited
281 websites 98 of them being porno
graphic disgusting experts have
authenticated the search history by it
coinciding with Vaseline purchases
plug your ears cat this is disgusting
but the man knew his way around PornHub
a place that I have never heard of what
could it be PornHub
Hunter was reportedly into lonely widows
which is no surprise as he also was
dating his deceased brother's widow
Hallie The Daily Mail also says Hunter
recorded amateur videos of himself
having sex with prostitutes never
showing his face and then uploading them
to Pornhub under the username RH East
it's pretty gross but still better than
watching a Biden screw a whole country
[Music]
all right
as if that's not bad enough he allegedly
texted his dad a link to a porn site
back in 2018 or at least someone labeled
dad in his phone we don't know for sure
it was Joe although the video was called
hair sniffers in heat
and for a comment
oh no no look look I didn't I didn't get
any messages I didn't get any links
nobody sent me any links
I don't I don't even like those links I
don't like clicking on those
those links
why do they call them links anyway
they're not really links are they
they're like a
it's like a door to a
to another world
why is it so quiet
Tyrus
do you think at all that it's kind of
liberating for everyone to know your
predilections is that how you said
predilections you know because now I
mean you can't no one can afford this
much shame you know because it's too
costly at this level there's just so
much stuff it's just got to go like oh
it's out there I don't care because I
mean there's actually film of him
breaking wind
laughs
no I looked at it
I once was asked about what would happen
if
someone was to break into my computer
history and I once talked about the term
Beautiful Death of that's what a samurai
has been Dishonored yes he dresses in
all white and it's a nice folding thing
some flowers some cherry petals falling
down and then he has some ceremonial
swords and he takes the sharpest one in
my case I take the bluntest one and he
thrusts it inside himself until he
bleeds and it's called A Beautiful Death
right that's what you think that's what
I would do
Hunter apparently is a lot more braver
than I am and at this point what's left
I mean yeah what is left when you
searching for lonely widows and crack
moms yes I mean
bottom you're like the devil's going are
you all right down there like nothing
there's nothing worse than that so I'm
not it's too far for me brizz I just
wow yeah you know oh yeah cat none of us
could survive this kind of lifestyle
unless we were part of a political
family right it'd be like you know his
unless your daddy's in the white house I
mean this is incredible he's still
selling half a million dollar paintings
after this are you jealous yeah
of course he just gets to Wild out and
everyone's like you know yes I could I I
could never get away with this stuff
um but I don't I mean I don't think like
all the porn searching is like a big
deal no I think it's actually a problem
that he wasn't more addicted to porn
because if he's watching more porn he
wouldn't have time for all the Shady
business dealings that's true it does
eat up a lot yeah I'm like addicted to
porn no he was into porn yes he wasn't
addicted if he was that addicted he
would have been declining the calls from
the Chinese officials to watch more porn
that is true so amazing how you lose
track of time when you go down that uh
path but I was literally in yeah he was
really yeah used his own movies yeah
yeah he's never he doesn't even know
what he is
he's
the smartest guy he had all these
business dealings and he had he was able
to juggle a porn addiction at the same
time
look I I don't have a problem with the
guy
I don't know it doesn't bother me I mean
look you you I'm 44 years old you you
live through the horrors of this world
and the numbing pain after a while and
you're just desperately trying to feel
something
I get it I just get it and I want to
hang out with him you know
your friends you know what I mean yeah
you're like you're in your 40s what are
you guys doing today oh we're gonna have
a dinner party and we're gonna then go
to Dave and Buster's and then he's like
you want to go Cruise a few MILFs that
hit a wall and they're doing crack
like yes yes I want to let's see what
it's all about yeah well the Secret
Service pick me up we're gonna go to the
Chateau Marmont I got an eight ball yeah
Hunter if you're watching I am inviting
you to Joey roses
to drink with me and then hang out in
with me in the bathroom
laughs
I am obligated to ask you this Kennedy
because you you know that it's oh it
it's the cliched question but if imagine
if Hunter was a member of the Trump
family or any Republican family I know
that's such an easy layer are you trying
to get me to imagine what Eric Trump's
porn
he uses a private browser he's no idiot
I wonder if he likes juicy twinks like I
do
um I'm just trying to imagine a couple
things but I'm trying to imagine what uh
Widow porn is like is it like a woman
dressed in black lace the Black Veil yes
funeral home and a man comes over and
says Mrs Widow I'm so sorry
I've got I've got yeah I've got some
kleenex for you here hold on it's in my
pants
there you go
um like what is what is Widow porn what
is what is the setup like and the second
thank God we're coming out of a pandemic
where everyone can cover themselves in
Purell can you imagine shaking hands
with him yeah that's just like just that
picture of him behind you it's like
I can't imagine like he like monkey pox
would be a relief yes
he gave Hunter pox to monkeys yeah the
monkeys are like no thank you yeah
exactly the monkeys are like I can't
believe you slept with Hunter
it's like Rick James man cocaine it's a
hell of a drug yeah
but uh I guess his was like meth right
was it meth I guess cracker no I didn't
to say no to drugs
I like ending every segment like that
you're our dare program I know I know I
dare you to do drugs not see what I did
there I don't dare you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else